hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid games unleashes I've um I've been
playing them every day and now I've
skipped two days my daughter's been uh
bit a bit ill and uh hasn't been going
to kindergarten so uh today she's
feeling much better and I do have some
time to play uh to play one rapid so we
we can continue uh and we get the white
pieces uh let me just check who our
opponent is our opponent is uh David
David 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 and we're going to
go E4 uh and hope for the best so our
opponent is rated 2294 so a bit higher
rated than us uh not not just a bit like
130 rating points uh but that makes it
all the better as we can win a lot more
rating if we win uh but you should never
uh think about rating when you're
playing or or even when you're not
playing you should just um try and play
good chess and everything else uh is
irrelevant if if you can if you focus on
that then
rating will follow if you focus on
rating I mean chess will not
follow so okay our opponent is asking
for it I do have to go for the Evans
Gambit as I always say it is the best
opening there ever was and will be so
we'll see how our opponent will deal
with
it and uh he's considering or maybe he's
just like making a sandwich or something
but uh yeah we'll see if he if he
takes uh not taking on B4 isn't uh all
that impressive so I never really uh
never really uh did any work on how to
play if your opponent declines it but uh
then you just got a free B4 in and you
should be happy with that you you will
have a B5 in the
future so our opponent could actually be
very much confused with this B4 push
maybe maybe this is the first time he
ever encounters the Evans Gambit which
which is a uh you know a special moment
in everyone's life so if that is the
case then uh good for David uh I mean we
don't know how old David is he could be
six he could be 60 uh I've seen some
people who are 60 and I have never heard
of about the Evans Gambit so it is
possible uh but yeah he's definitely
wasting some time here
really really calculating it
deeply okay so he takes he calculated
everything
chances are it's I mean it's a rapid
game he does have a lot of time uh
probably he just went to make a sandwich
but who knows we'll see if he yeah okay
so he plays very standard
moves yeah although if he will be taking
a lot of time on each of these moves it
could very well mean that he's
encountered it for the first time maybe
not that he's heard of it for the first
time but maybe he just never played
against it and yeah this is a very very
common sense move on how to how to deal
with
it we'll see if he finds Bishop to B6
which is uh Black's strongest reply in
any line of the events then uh you can
be sure that
uh uh that he has seen it before if not
well
um yeah we'll just Castle or do we need
to Castle now let's go Bishop A3 first
first go Bishop A3
first yeah the queen is very nicely okay
so he does go Bishop B6 uh he knows his
stuff uh he knows his stuff but now
we're going to play something a little
bit weird we're going to play Bishop to
B5 which is not a move that you usually
play but uh it will allow my Bishop to
remain on this diagonal now and now I'm
already threatening to win a piece here
yeah he can play that but the bishop is
here so he cannot play
B5 yeah although I've never I don't
think I've ever seen Bishop to B5 being
played uh but okay so he goes Bishop to
A5 Now bring up the the B5 Pawn makes
sense yeah now with D5 he's going to
play but no okay so he's going to play
B5 I'm going to take he's going to take
and the my Bishop is stuck here so even
that makes sense yeah definitely
does but it it does but it looks really
weird really does look weird
H yeah we're kind of committed
here we have to play it and and and and
see what
happens
yeah maybe maybe also just nah it's too
we'll be too too soon for that but yeah
he did uh manage to capture my light
Square
Bishop but okay I
mean I will check after the game uh what
is uh what is uh what what is so weird
about this bishop to B5 move maybe he
can maybe he can refute it this way very
easily uh but yeah Okay so we've
deviated from all the standard stuff and
now he once this this gets cleared he
will have to play B5 of course unless
I'm missing something yeah he will play
B5 we'll probably just capture here and
once he captures I'm going to capture
here he's going to capture here and uh
yeah we Castle the safety and then we
figure out probably some C4 Knight to C3
action he will have the semiopen a file
for the rook and continue developing
nicely on the king side so I don't think
I've I've gotten all that
much um but yeah
he he uh figured out a way out of it
very nicely but that's uh that's sort of
the weakness of the Evans Gambit if your
opponent figures out Bishop to B6 then
you're then you're on your
own you will not be winning a swift game
uh but still yeah I don't know why my
opponent is spending so much
time am I blind is there a move other
than
B5 like nah there
isn't a fun position like no no there
isn't he has to play B5 he probably
wants to just calculate it out yeah
that's uh that's something that I've
realized some people if if there's an
only move they will play it and then you
calculate later but some people I've
learned uh even though they have only
one move on the board let's say you're
in check and your only move is the move
the king they will still calculate like
six moves ahead uh without M making that
move which is uh I I guess it can be
done but you know make the move your
opponent makes a move and then you start
calculating I mean especially if you're
not sure if your opponent has an only
move once you make your only move so but
yeah I've seen this uh done by people
I've seen I've seen it done in classical
chess people have done it against me uh
even in uh like it was maybe 10 years
ago in the catian team championship I
played a I played a game where my
opponent had an only move and he just
spent like 45 minutes without making it
uh so it was a bit weird uh but yeah uh
so now we have to decide what to do
first we're going to take the pawn
and then we are going to C or do we
capture
here yeah the problem is if we capture
and uh if uh he we capture he's going to
capture back with the queen he doesn't
have to take the bishop right away
because my Bishop is trapped that's uh
that's the point
here uh so
yeah so we do have to take on B5 first
or maybe we don't maybe we can just take
here he takes here and then we play what
nah he's just going to take with the
queen and then we have no smart
ideas
uh yeah so we'll take
here take
here and probably just Castle probably
just
Castle or do we need the castle can we
go for for something sneak yeah he will
play Bishop to E6 do we have time for
Knight G5 maybe to guard the D4 Pawn as
well and threaten F7 what's his move on
Knight
G5 yeah very
interesting or right Castle yeah no he's
next move is Bishop to E6 he will not
even if I Castle he will not capture on
e4 he's going to go Bishop to E6
which is very
strong it's very very
strong I guess we go Knight
G5 to stop a bishop to E6 yeah he
defends this way and what do we have now
yeah now we have now we have a whole
bunch of nothing yeah yeah we're going
to have to Castle
here at least he can't play uh he's not
is he willing enough no he I don't think
he is yeah he's just going to Castle to
safety and then we can strike forward
maybe with F4 we are we are neglecting
our development a little bit here uh but
it's also something that happens in the
Evans when yeah you have this bishop on
A5 uh do I have something to worry
about do should I play should I play
King H1 first yeah okay for the moment I
don't have to do anything about
that
huhuhuh yeah no we're not in a rush
let's just move the H let's go F4 let's
go F4 he will have to capture he he
can't really allow captures due to
this the Knight here yeah it can go to
G4 but yeah then okay can connect nicely
with the queen here and he could go for
some okay so he will
take he will
take now
E5
yeah it's not the best I mean even if he
takes uh he does he does get the pawns
so it's a very yeah okay so he will go
for this check which we of
course yeah okay that's
nice very nice
um what do we think of that do we like
it do we think it's
lame uh what do we think about E6 here
he'll probably play something something
like
F3 no F3 is not good because we capture
first and then go here yeah uh Rook
captures also very nasty stuff if if I
play yeah no he can't do
it
um
yeah is there no there isn't yeah how to
develop here maybe
to yeah we'll play E6 just just for
fun just for fun we'll play E6 but
uh he probably has already uh a
reply as this it it was the the obvious
move uh but then we try to get our
pieces our Queens side pieces somehow
into the game we're not going to win the
game uh without developing that yeah he
goes for checkmate here as he
should as he should yeah that's very
nice oh that's very nice and very very
difficult to defend you're going to have
to capture here
once we going to have to capture here
once and uh probably just bring the
Knight back yeah it's sad but what are
you going to
do what are you going to do holding the
Queen back to B2 is weird because then I
can't move the Knight otherwise Rook
captures on A3 and then I have to move
the queen so my best bet is that uh he
is uh maybe going to play suboptimal
moves as he's getting very low on time
but chances are he's not going
to
um and yeah I mean it's not like it's
not like it's a super terrible position
but he does have the bishop pair here
and and I would probably very much enjoy
playing this with black uh more than I
am enjoying it with white yeah so still
threatening mate and yeah is there is
there a way to do something
here other the Knight F3 yeah I don't
think there is I don't think there is
he's going to unpin here and then we
have to get our pieces into the game
somehow yeah let's shift the bishop back
here probably going to play not d D5
yeah he can play but if he plays D5 he
closes this diagonal of course he's not
going to play
that yeah that's super nice super
nice
[Music]
mhm
yeah it's still nothing spectac Tacker
we can still get uh this Knight into the
game but no not not just now because he
will just capture
it
uh yeah we have to do it like this no
other way to do
it all right so we're holding and yeah
okay so he will
take
um he will take what do I take with I
will take with the Rook let's make it
interesting let's make it
interesting yeah if I if I move the
queen then he could just sacrifice the
queen for the rook and the deliver
checkmates but as long as my queen
defends it that's out of the question
okay so now what is Queen
C5 what is Queen C5 other than attacking
The Rook he wants me to move the rook
and then push F3
probably but I don't know if I can
afford
that yeah he will just play okay so he
goes for checkmate
here yeah very strong I have to give up
The Rook there's no other
way
have to give up the rook and somehow
develop ah this is not
easy I'm hanging hanging by a threat
here let's go
here he will move the bishop probably
with something like C5 to get the E3
Square for his Rook he wants to he has
to attack my queen uh um to be able to
advance the pawn so we're going
to can we counter it somehow no we don't
no we can't yeah I have to play
something like
this it's ugly but we have to play it no
this will just get get me checkmated
wow yeah that's
silly is there a way out of this any way
any way out of
this
yeah maybe he falls for the no even this
does yeah I thought maybe Rook captures
Queen captures and then Rook checkmates
but the bishop will be covering the E3
Square as well but maybe we can
uh yeah I don't think
so yeah rookie three and is the game
over rookie three and it's game
over
maybe
okay
so we're going to put our Queen to F2
it's it's a bad move but
uh bad move but uh maybe he like plays
Rook captures and C3 just oh no he does
this okay so that that's what I was
hoping for kind
of kind of kind of what I was hoping
for but uh yeah it's probably also kind
of what he was hoping for yeah now just
Queen D5 yeah everything works now Rook
Rook e one Checkmate yeah very nicely
done Mr David uh nice game and excellent
defense against the Evans
Gambit uh let me just quickly check what
we could have done better here after
this um yeah Queen to D7 move we played
Bishop to A3 he went Bishop to B6 and
Bishop to B5 okay so yeah like the yeah
the idea is just a standard capture and
to allow Knight to A5 but I wanted to
try Bishop to B5 I've never actually
tried it A6 yeah uh I went here he went
here D5 okay so D5 already the losing
move wow yeah it it certainly felt that
way yeah now if uh if I capture he
captures and I just Castle sort of still
yeah but
D5 uh sort of ruins the position for me
so this is what happened captures
captures yeah now it's just a very very
very hard to play he played it
excellently yeah not much to be done
here Bishop to B7 yeah and here it's
uh barely barely holding
on and yeah not much to be done here he
played it after that uh after that
Fiasco on the queen Side by myself uh it
was a it was a pretty bad uh pretty bad
position and my opponent exploited it
very well and he he won deservingly uh
so yeah there you have it not the not
the best uh explanation of the events
unfortunately but you know what are you
going to do uh time to I I will improve
on that line and we'll uh we'll come out
stronger hopefully for the next one uh
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day